hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel today's video is sponsored by
Gundam Evolution and if you haven't
already heard of this series you are
watching good gaming news which is a
series where I specifically cover gaming
news that I feel positively about
because there is enough negativity in
the space as is not to say that's not
warranted but the truth is good gaming
use doesn't get enough views for anyone
else to cover it so I'm doing my best as
somebody who doesn't care about views
so there's actually like a bunch of
stories this week um and I didn't do the
episode last week or the show last week
just because there was so much news out
of TGs that it felt like it just would
have been a flood of things so I just
skipped the week
um and we technically have to start
today with what I would consider to be
extremely negative to lead into the
positive so I don't tend to talk about
leaks I'm not going to show the leak um
a lot of you probably already know about
it as is I think leaks suck but
basically for the first time ever and in
probably one of the biggest leaks in
video game history
um
just
colossal uh unprecedented
um Grand Theft Auto 6 leaked and we have
this message here from Rockstar Games
who said we recently suffered a network
intrusion in which an unauthorized third
party illegally accessed and downloaded
confidential information from our
systems including early development
footage for the next Grand Theft Auto at
this time we did not anticipate any
disruption to our live gamer game
Services nor any long-term effect on the
development of our ongoing projects
which is good uh we're extremely
disappointed to have any details of our
next game shared with you all in this
way our work on the Grand Theft Auto
game will continue as planned and we
remain as committed as ever to
delivering an experience to you our
players that truly exceeds your
expectations we will update everyone
again soon and of course we'll properly
introduce you to this next game when it
is ready we want to thank everyone for
their ongoing support through this
situation the Rockstar Games Team
interesting that they never actually
call it Grand Theft Auto 6. I guess
because the game's not formally been
announced it's only been leaked again I
just think leaks suck and I want to be
specific that I think that that includes
players a lot of players are like what
the hell I'm so excited about this house
is this bad for me you were robbed of
like a proper reveal you got to see
something uh that wasn't designed for
you to see it that wasn't shaped for you
to see it and what is usually like an
epic event can you imagine the hype that
we would have all had waiting for an
official reveal of Grand Theft Auto 6
like that would have been so much
stronger if this stuff just hadn't have
happened I just it's a bummer for the
excitement of fans it sucks for Rockstar
um it sucks for every devil the team I
just it sucks so some spiteful people
being like well they should treat their
employees better and I feel like that is
better proof than anything that you
don't care about their employees that
you just like say that as a talking
point to have a jab at them if you
actually care about the employees you
would know that this is an awful
experience for them to go through and
that they feel like [ __ ] it seems weird
to like hope that they feel like [ __ ]
because you've heard stories about how
they feel like [ __ ] is all I'm saying so
I think it sucks but what this sparked
is something that I think is very cool
this is an article from PC Gamo that
says devs show off how bad early game
builds look after moans about GTA 6's
visuals essentially um a really bad
tweet went viral where somebody said
something akin to this looks like crap
as everyone knows art is the first thing
done in the game so this is like a big
red flag which is completely wrong art
is not ever potentially concept art but
otherwise not ever the first thing done
in game development and as a response to
that terrible tweet
um the guy really doubled down like to
the extent that now I think he's trying
to go so far that it sounds like
trolling but I don't think he was
trolling originally so then game
developers are all over Twitter have
responded to this this is from Paul
aireth who said since Graphics are the
first thing finished in a video game and
control one multiple awards for
excellence in graphic series footage
from the beginning of game development
and I just look at the way she's dressed
that's so funny she did not end up
looking like that at all well that's
pretty good amazing look at all those
textures and I love seeing this stuff
like I love seeing behind the scenes
footage of games I love what skate is
doing with actually and Dead Space kind
of as well with actually showing us
footage of games and development I guess
that must be a thing that EA is okay
with of all Publishers it's really nice
to show plays how it works because then
I think a lot of the frustrations of
players sometimes have on social media
would be lessened because if they
understand how things are made
basically there's a thing where
sometimes players say things like but
why did the devs think of this would be
so [ __ ] easy to do and it's like it's
valid that you wish that whatever the
thing you're talking about is in the
game promise you it's not easy to do and
maybe you would feel less frustrated or
they would be less like the lazy game
developer nonsense on social media if
there was a little bit more transparency
so it's something that I really really
hope there's more of and obviously I
spend like a significant amount of the
time on this channel it's a big part of
why I still have this channel trying to
talk to devs and get those perspectives
this one is so good he's a thunderjaw
from an early build of horizon zero Dawn
oh beautiful graphical Fidelity call to
the lamb here tweeting Graphics are the
first thing finished in a video game
here's what early versions of Call to
the lamb looked like
that's so funny no way
[Music]
so glad that this crappy story that I
think sucks for everyone just prompted
people to share their stuff it's so cool
he is the downhill Chase section played
in Block match versus art block match
versus final art there are a million
stages between block mesh is super
common even like three months out of
development you can still see block
Master art block match it's very very
common this is from Kurt who's a
director at uh uh naughty dog I think he
was I'm not sure if he is anymore
foreign
iconic scene to see this way too right
I guess he tweeted this originally in
2017 but it signal boosted it
it's so cool this one is from Josh
Kolinski he's a senior game designer at
uh Bungie
[Laughter]
oh incredible yeah essentially just
something that like I'm glad that the
crappy situation sparked this response
from The Game Dev community and for
people to be more transparent about it
and again it's something I hope to talk
about a little bit more at length is
like what pre-production actually looks
like into production actually looks like
because I think a lot of players just
don't really know how games come
together and how like just how
constantly devs of fighting everything
breaking at all times it's such an
inefficient practice so yeah just a
positive on a negative story ultimately
hello everyone it is time for me to talk
to you about Gundam Evolution I am a
very big Gundam fan I have been for a
really long time and you may have
already seen me play the beta but now
Gundam Evolution the full release is
upon us Gundam evolution is a free to
play 6v6 team-based shooter from Bandai
Namco online you can pilot units from
across the Gundam Multiverse in high
intensity 6v6 objective based combat and
it totally is objective based and very
competitive if you really do have to be
switched on you got to select the right
Gundams make sure that you're pairing
them with your other team members of
course each unit has unique attack and
skill loadouts that of course all
complement each other so you have to be
very cooperative and it is a very
strategic team-based shooter the combat
is super high speed and you could
utilize a unique boost system to
accelerate into action as you take on
the battlefield they have also already
spoken about how they intend to
continuously evolve the world of Gundam
Evolution with A continuous flow of new
mobile suit units Maps customization
items and game modes to explore and
whether you're shooting your various
settings for gameplay customizing the
look of your mobile suit or setting your
player profile items there are so many
ways to adjust your Gundam Evolution so
that it feels unique to you so click the
link in the description for more
information about the game I've already
streamed it once and I'll be streaming
it again on Monday you might even get to
play with us if you join now it's free
to play so why not like I said Link in
the description to check out more about
the game next up uh Ubisoft wants to
make more focused games rather than have
one game do everything where every hour
needs to count I think a lot of us are
probably in a similar position right now
where there was a period of time where
Ubisoft was my favorite publisher around
the era where they also released Child
of Light and Valiant Hearts I loved what
Ubisoft was putting out I loved Far Cry
3 I loved Assassin's Creed 2 through
Revelations and I mean Black Flag as
well they were like putting out a lot of
really really really good games and I
think what has stopped me from playing
as many Ubisoft games recently is
they feel too similar
and too big so you can only take so many
of that same thing
um and this to me feels like there may
be aware that they're losing some of
that player base and this is kind of a
response to it so this is an IGN article
from math personal it says Ubisoft has
said that its current approach to game
development is to approach projects with
Focus to ensure each game is honored to
its target audience rather than
attempting to cater to a very broad
non-specific crowd which I do think
they've done recently at a recent
Ubisoft press Precinct briefing vice
president of editorial fawzi mesma spoke
as part of a presentation about how
Focus rather than broad ideas was an
important part of the editorial board's
current development process in a
subsequent interview with IGN he
expanded on that idea saying that the
company doesn't want one game to do
everything and in an era of games of
service live service video games I would
have bet actually that Ubisoft was going
down this path that there would be one
Ghost Recon and one Watchdogs and one
Assassin's Creed
um that you know acted as a fortnite
style ever expanding experience because
it's so easy to monetize that it's
easier to do that especially in a live
service game where other players are
President other players are creating
engaging content and other players are
creating entertainment than releasing a
single player game every year one of the
cheapest things you can do in game
development which is why we saw so many
Battle Royale clones it's not because
they thought it was a cash grab it's
because it's easy to develop it's
because other players actually create
most of the content you make one map you
make the weapons obviously you have to
balance them and you have to place them
but even sometimes that's randomized
it's the other players that keep the
players interesting so they just
entertain each other rather than you
having to put an NPC at every location
on the map or whatever it's very easy
live service games are very easy to get
people addicted to and to monetize
especially when you've got like loyalty
so that's kind of where I would have
even thought that they were going but
apparently not they went on to say we
want to be okay with making a decision
around the one game and go we're going
to go for that and we're going to commit
and we're going to be okay that it can
make those kind of people happy and make
you know everybody and that's okay we
believe that a more focused game is
better for the people that like that
kind of game here's why I think this is
really good news
I don't think they have any reason to
say that if it's not true it's not going
to sell units it's not just marketing um
because outside of people like me most
people are not going to care about this
quote at all it's
it has no impact on actual sales my
concern with Ubisoft making a new
Splinter Cell was always that I didn't
think it would be very good because
Ubisoft have kind of worked themselves
into a little bit of a corner where they
use a lot of the same systems to make
their games same map similar AI
essentially they share
thanks because that is a more efficient
way for them to make games and I was
like okay if ubisoft's gonna make a new
Splinter Cell they're going to want it
to be as accessible as possible
um appeal to the broadest audience
possible which a stealth game absolutely
does not and probably depend on some of
those systems
such as your you know capturing the
tower point or whatever it is which
means that I don't want them to make
another split assault game or at least
they can make it I just don't think I
would want to play it and saying this
makes me think that maybe I'm wrong and
that they are aware of that issue maybe
when us if the stealth focused
Assassin's Creed Mirage was an example
of this messmark confirmed that the
series was part of that strategy and the
franchise at large was a good example of
the approach there's many different
types of players that could enjoy
Assassin's Creed and we're focusing on
all of them instead of making one game
that is supposed to cater for every
potential Assassin's Creed fan so for
the people who want to go back to the
roots we are making a game for them with
Mirage which makes me too excited about
it and hopefully for others that didn't
get to enjoy that classic when it came
out we're also making a multi-play
Experience mobile experience a big RPG
experience there's so many different
types of elements that we cater for and
that also exemplifies the editorial
Vision that we set and which we're not
making the one game for everybody but
we're making a game for you and focused
and we're committing to the decisions
that we're making on it this design for
Focus links to another Ubisoft goal that
every hour played should count so breath
it's not what we're aiming for as much
as its depth of the experience going
towards making sure every hour counts of
players and they feel that it's time
well spent so of course maybe I'm being
optimistic this is a show in which we
have optimism and I feel positively
about this direction and I hope they
take it seriously next up the cyberpunk
2077 steam Play account jumps after Edge
Runners update and Netflix anime this is
from Games Radar clearly
Henry Osler the action RPG is one of the
most popular single player games on
valve's storefront right now so we plug
2077 certainly hasn't had the smoothest
of ride since it's released almost two
years ago but recently there's been a
surge of players tonight City thanks to
the game's latest patch and the highly
polished Netflix anime series cyberpunk
Edge Runners which I still haven't
watched maybe this weekend I'll get
around to it yesterday the number of
concurrents I would want 2077 players
peaked at 37 000 beating lights of other
popular single-player games like Elder
ring which had 31 000 alongside Grand
Theft Auto 5 and Destiny 2 which just
always have a million players
if we compare this to August peak of 16
000 the amount of players delving into
CD project Red's action RPG has more
than doubled in the past month the
game's Rising popularity is likely due
to its newest update which introduces
various fixes and gameplay improvements
as well as extra features Additionally
the recently released Netflix anime
cyberpunk Edge run is has been a big hit
with viewers and has likely spurred many
to test off their copy of cyberpunk 2077
and I really think this is great news I
love a comeback
um I do think that uh video game
Community I used to be like this can
have a pretty bad habit of um
[ __ ] on things when they're bad and
not allowing any celebration when
they're good I got a lot of flack when I
was a journalist for uh an article where
I said that I really liked something
that EA was doing which is the originals
program I'm still very supportive of The
Originals program people just criticized
me for like saying anything good about
EA and it's like well hang on now if we
can say the things we don't like I think
we should also celebrate the things we
do like but in this case they did
something that's very very rare which is
continue to support it after launch what
most companies would do would be drop it
move on as fast as possible and make
something else but they actually dropped
other projects uh in favor of working on
fixing cyberpunk 2077 and it still sucks
that it launched the way that it did the
console versions were inexcusable I mean
they knew that that's why they didn't
give people console review codes I
suppose obviously the PC experience was
much better which is I think indicated
in the review scores I had a very good
time at launch but it's only improved
since then and it's like this doesn't
excuse games launching in a bad State at
all but it is still good when there
improved later right don't launch bad in
the first place you shouldn't for sure
but if you do for some reason which is
usually a publisher like making you push
something out the door to make some
[ __ ] money the dev team being able to
continue to work on it to improve it to
get it to a better standard to get it to
their own standard to get it to the
standard that players deserve awesome we
feel good about it and it seems like
people are really enjoying it and I love
that because there's a lot about this
game that I really really really love
course full disclosure I'm in the game
but um I still really enjoyed it the
story is very very fun and this is a
great turnaround for them and something
that I think we should encourage I felt
really similarly about no man's sky but
I hated that on launch I thought it was
terrible and now I love no man's Sky I
just think you love to see it again
obviously avoid it in the first place I
think what happened to cyberpunk is
going to make a few more Publishers a
lot Shyer about releasing games in a bad
State like that but if you do for some
reason fix them you have my support
alright next up this is something that I
definitely feel positively about
in a in a I feel positively that this is
being considered I'm not saying that I
think that any of this Crackdown should
happen I don't have the know how to say
that and I'm currently not concerned
about a monopoly it's not quite enough
but I think all of these big
Acquisitions that a lot of the uh video
game industry is facing right now the
big acquisition of the 2020s should be
scrutinized heavily every single part of
it should be checked we should make sure
that our industry continues to be
healthy story is Microsoft Activision
acquisition expected to face deeper
investigations in UK EU it says
Microsoft 68.7 billion acquisition of
Activision Blizzard is expected to be
investigated extensively by both UK and
EU regulations earlier this month the
UK's competition and markets Authority
recommended it begin a second phase
investigation into impact of the deal
concern that Microsoft's ownership of
Activision Blizzard would result in a
substantial lessening of competition
within a market or markets in the United
Kingdom Microsoft was given five
business days to supply evidence that
would Ally these concerns but the
financial times reports that it opted
not to do so which I think probably
means they think they're safe and I
suspect they are too source is familiar
with the situation told the Ft that
Microsoft believed they were no there
were no obvious commitments it could
make the CMA would be likely to accept
that's interesting as such an in-depth
investigation is expected to start this
week the APT sources also expect a
similar situation with in the European
Union one point of contention Remains
the implications for Xbox's main Rivals
Sony especially with the possibility of
making Call of Duty one of the biggest
game franchises in the world exclusive
to Microsoft's platforms I feel like
there's a bit much hubbub about that
it's plateaued I don't know obviously
it's still huge but whatever in the wake
of the cma's recommendations for a
longer investigation Activision Blizzard
CEO Bobby kotec I believe he's still
there said he still expects the
acquisition to be approved and completed
by the end of June 2023. so yeah
um I don't think anything is going to
happen with this one but I do feel like
I want all of these to be investigated
literally every single one of them you
want to want to maintain our industry
and and making sure that there's healthy
competition is a really big part of that
of course all right the last couple of
these are really quick we have another
mod here I do like highlighting mods in
these because I used to cover mods
um and I find them very fun this one is
the Half-Life 2 VR mod that launches
today on Steam bringing free VR support
to valve's classic adventure which is so
so cool the long-awaited VR mod for
Half-Life 2 is available for free in
beta starting today bringing the iconic
valve title A near native level of VR
immersion we've been waiting for this
began nearly 10 years ago and yeah the
whole thing so the entire game is in VR
it launched on Steam and Early Access
for free though obviously you do need a
copy of the game but it's it's not an
expensive game I've got a video here so
[ __ ] cool dude it's just so cool
shine Mr Freeman
wow
I love it
I love it
makes me want to play it again um it
includes full room scale VR with track
motion controls physically walk around
pick up objects and climb lattice the
only way virtual reality allows sorry
the way only virtual reality allows
realistic weapon interactions radio menu
tends to be the standard ammo storage of
your shoulder I love that functional ion
sights two-handed weapons and manual
reloading control options comfort
features like motion bidnet which helps
a lot the motion vignette um
makes it black around the screen and it
just helps you realize that you're not
in an open space a third person vehicle
camera no currently no teleport movement
option which does help a lot of people
it's really interesting I did a study on
VR while I was working at IGN and the
thing that actually makes people sick is
your body thinks you're poisoned I'm
sure if you've listened to playlist
listen we've spoken about this um your
body thinks that you are sick because it
doesn't understand why you aren't moving
the same way that the world is moving so
it makes you want to throw up and
playable on any VR headset supported by
steam VR awesome the last one something
very simple that I just thought was
really really neat is this
make myself nice and small down here
it's just so cool
if you can't already tell
portal with Ray tracing for the first
time
[Music]
computer aided it looks so good
cake and grief counseling will be
available at the conclusion of the test
one of the best games ever made
and I mean that like with heavy emphasis
I think portal is
[ __ ] up there portal might be the
best game ever made
Apollo 2.
so yeah to get ray tracing support
awesome and it's pretty easy
love it love it so cool
um that is the end of today's episode
everybody huge thank you to gundam
Evolution for sponsoring this episode of
the show there'll be a link in the
description to where you can check out
more of the game I played it last night
I'll be playing it on Monday as well
probably with viewers so if you want to
jump into twitch chat it's free to play
you can play with me as long as we're in
the same region I think it has to be
North America that is it for me today
everybody I hope you enjoyed this week's
good gaming news I will see you guys
next time